my name is Dr Peter Grossman and I am
the director of the grossen burn center
at West Hills Hospital thank you for
doing this with us what's Jay's status
right now what can you tell me about how
he's doing so Mr Leno sustained
significant injuries the burns were very
significant to his face and his hands
and his chest so I don't want to
minimize the seriousness of his injuries
but I also want to emphasize that he's
doing very well he's got a very strong
attitude he's a very strong individual
and he's a person who really is looking
to move forward to try to find a way to
get past this episode of his life and
then to get back to doing what he
normally likes to do which is to be out
there and entertain and be with the
people and I think at some point soon
he'll get there but I've had to tell him
that for the time being he needs to sit
back and take care of Jay yeah he loves
making people laugh obviously how's his
sense of humor is it is it is it there
is he how are his spirits
you know I think he would rather not be
here he's obviously concerned uh about
uh what happened he's really concerned
about
the people that he's committed to I I
had to tell him uh that you'll you'll be
there but you've got to please just take
care of yourself
that being said he's very compliant with
whatever we ask him to do his spirits
are good he understands the seriousness
of what he's gone through but he also
realizes what the injury is he needs to
get through it in the process of being
here he's been incredibly kind and
appreciative to the nursing staff and
everybody else who's been taking care of
him he's gone around and been joking
with the staff he's helped deliver
cookies to some of the Pediatric
patients that are here in the ward so
we've been very uh very appreciative of
what he's done to lighten the
environment here in the burn center now
what percentage of his face was burned
when he came in
uh his Burns included the lower half of
his face his cheeks and his chin and his
ears and his neck
so what you spoke about having him in a
hyperbaric chamber to help uh alleviate
some of the burns from going from second
to third degree burns how much time does
he spend in a hyperbaric chamber
he's in the hyperbaric chamber uh about
two hours a day an hour in the morning
an hour in the afternoon
and
you spoke about his first surgery that
was performed earlier this week
um you guys it was just giving him skin
grafts what can you tell me about that
process
the process that uh
Jay went is this process of virtually
all patients who have significant burn
injuries go through they are put to
sleep so that they we minimize pain and
then we have to remove the unhealthy
tissue and you remove the unhealthy
tissue through a number of different
ways a process known as debridement
and sometimes that's scrubbing it down
and sometimes it's shaving it down the
deeper areas of burn have to be removed
a little bit more aggressively and then
once the unhealthy tissue is removed
we put a temporary biological dressing
in this situation human cadaver skin to
create an environment in which his body
can be stimulated to heal but that's
only temporary and has to be removed and
then ultimately he'll need a definitive
layer of tissue to help him heal as
quickly as possible with his minimal
negative effects and that's what our
game plan is going forward are you able
to see how many surgeries he'll need at
this point or is that a
case-by-case basis
at this point it's a little bit
premature to determine how many
surgeries you will need our hope is that
we'll be able to get them home soon
after that there'll be some follow-up he
has a great team of personal Physicians
and friends and hopefully we'll be able
to be part of his healing process and I
think hopefully when everything is all
said and done he'll do quite well is
there a chance that Jay could have
permanent disfigurement from these
injuries
it's a little too early to tell what's
going to happen it's always possible in
Burn injuries especially when you have
significant damage from the situation as
as he did hopefully with aggressive care
and a little bit of good luck we'll be
able to get him through this with the
minimal long-term effects but
unfortunately at this point I just can't
give you a definitive answer is there a
typical length of time that patients
that come in with Jay's type of injuries
that it takes them to heal as fully as
they're going to heal
burn injuries go through a long process
for the road to recovery depending on
the severity and depth of the injury
some people can heal relatively quickly
if the injuries are superficial some end
up developing scarring over several
months and then it takes several years
to get them to a point of maximal
improvement so it's really a individual
case-by-case basis in which we make a
determination on that our hope is that
Jay will do well quickly but again at
this point it's a little too early to
tell it might be tough to say at this
point how long do you think you'll need
to stay here in the in the center for
we hope to get them out soon but we need
to get him through the process and uh
he understands that our goal is to get
the maximal Improvement that we can and
he's patient enough but certainly
pushing us to move forward as quickly as
we can so we're trying to
get our best results but also realize
that Jay as everybody wants to get home
as soon as we can hopefully as soon as
we have a little bit more information as
to how he's healing we'll be able to
answer that question